what did you make of what - uh Nick
Brown was saying that well we and first
of all it's not really a fine is it this
is money that's already been allocated
and paid by the government to GTR and
they're just telling them how to spend
it and it's not a surprise that it's not
a fine because Chris Grayling has been
completely implicated and that this
whole strategy of trendy improve driver
in the operation which quite rightly has
been the the main cause not the only
cause because the company was failing in
2015 even before the industrial region
but that has been the main cause of the
disruption of course has been management
practices have been absolutely appalling
but this this is this policy of flavor
on the operation has been pushed from
the Department of Transport and now we
have this charade of him imposing a
frame which doesn't really a fine I mean
but let's be honest I mean this business
of driver or operated trains I mean the
driver only trains I mean this is really
a fig leaf this is a battle an
old-fashioned battle over trade union
power isn't it they're trying to break
you and you're resisting not no not at
all and if you'd have been on that train
at Watford and 2011 which are sorry 2016
September 2016 which derailed the driver
stuck in the cab and a woman guard
derailed that took out all those
passengers herself they trained them all
got the emergency services on site
blocked the rains turned off the
electricity you wouldn't be saying that
and that's the thing even government
statistics show that only 30 percent of
the network which is greater than the
operation you have 70 percent for the
most serious accidents and they will not
answer that question what did you make
of Southern's point that they're
actually putting more people than ever
in front of the passengers in passenger
facing roles where they have these
driver only operated trains but they're
not because they have refused the
guarantee even a second person on a tray
and even if that second person doesn't
say if they critical what they say they
will Gloucester sombrely but of course
when people go on and you leave that
rosters uncovered of people go sick that
rosters uncovered already they've had
thousands of trains and this hasn't just
the safety issues an accessibility issue
because you've got disabled people and
particularly disabled people against
cots who are going ruined and they can't
get on trains they have to pick up two
days in advance they get on the train
this isn't the issue though this Steve I
mean drivers are now southern trains
biggest most variable cost by you
constantly ratcheting up your demands
and pushing up your costs aren't you
bringing close to the day where we have
driverless trains
we couldn't we've got on one part of the
London transport network already well
first of all mainly the people that were
right we've got drivers out over driver
only operation but the main grip is the
guards which erm T represents and a
critical safety critical function and
they're trying to take that say at the
critical rule from the guards in order
to reduce costs and to get people like
GTR even bigger payouts and give give
their dividends dividend holders even
bigger payloads as well so this is this
this isn't they an issue words they've
gone and they lightly they've had a
strategy which has been ruled out from
the Department of Transport which has
said they cop costs by getting rid of a
safety critical role of a guard and
that's what we are totally against
alright Steve Hayley from the RMT gonna
leave it there thanks for joining me